Speaker 1: Hey, this might be interesting and
informative for you guys. As many of you know,
we get five or so thousand messages a day
across all of our different platforms. So like
YouTube comments, Facebook comments, emails,
Twitter replies, all these different things,
it's impossible to keep up with all of it. And
so we just can't. We just don't, OK? Every once
in a while, I like to engage with someone. So
like six months ago, an anti-vax emailer piqued
my interest and I said, Let me reply and let's see
what happens. And then I showed you that exchange,
and it was really, really wacky and disturbing. So
I did it again. I did it again. The other day, I
tweeted about the jobs numbers. Now, one of the
things we talked about on yesterday's bonus show
is in the midst of everything going on
politically. The jobs numbers, which are very
good. I mean, by every traditional measure, we're
basically at full employment now, many of you will
say, but a lot of people are still paycheck to
paycheck and the wages aren't good and the jobs
are low quality and b, oh, one hundred percent.
I'm with you all the way. I'm just saying that
by traditional measures which Republicans love to
use when it's a Republican president, we are very
close to what is considered full employment. And
last week, there were extraordinary jobs numbers.
Nearly 700000 new jobs were created in February.
We got the February numbers last week. These are
very, very good numbers. And so I simply tweeted
just to see kind of, you know, feel around what's
going on. The jobs numbers are very compelling,
just really not a very controversial tweet.
And a guy named Andrew responded to me and said,
You mean all the jobs Biden destroyed with his
lockdown mania? Now, as you can probably imagine,
there's like three or four layers on which this
is. This is very fallacious. We're talking about
job creation right now. Jobs were gaining jobs.
And of course, the job losses that we saw happened
under Donald Trump. And so the comment just it
doesn't make any sense. But I said, Hey, here's an
opportunity to try to figure out where this person
is coming from. So the first thing was I wanted
to establish, does the person even know what I'm
talking about? So I wrote back and I said, Did you
see the numbers today? Because they may not even
know that I think it was six hundred and seventy
eight thousand jobs were created in February. They
might just be responding without having any
idea what it is that I'm talking about. And
Andrew wrote back and said, Yeah. Meaning I did
see the jobs numbers. You can't brag about job
creation when your party caused all the job loss.
And again, bragging, we're just talking about
what are the jobs numbers? Is it good to create
jobs? And if it is, if you blame who's in the Oval
Office when jobs are lost, don't they get credit
when jobs are created now? You and I, hopefully
all of us have a more nuanced understanding of job
creation, and we understand that to some degree,
on a delay, job creation or job loss partially
reflects the actions of the president,
but to a significant degree has to do with global
factors, broader economic factors and and things
that have nothing to do with the president. But
you've got to be able to play both sides if you
blame a president for job loss. You've got to
at least give some equivalent amount of credit
for job creation. But this person is so confused.
You can't brag about job creation when your party
caused the job loss. So I followed up and tried
to explain. I said quote almost all the job loss
was in 2020, when Donald Trump was
president. What exactly are you referring to?
To which Andrew responded, The needless policies
that were under Democrats via their governors
and congressmen, they shut the country down
needlessly. It's been shown. Many times
lockdown policies didn't help stop the spread,
but hurt devastated the economy. And so,
so a couple of different things. First of all,
this experiment was basically a waste of time,
and what I mean by that is each response moved the
discussion to something different, and it didn't
even seem to comprehend that time moves forward
as we understand it and who was president at
different points in time. But it's also wrong on
some pretty basic facts. Number one, the economy,
even by the end. I mean, listen, I'm glad to admit
it because again, it has. It has a little to do
with the president, but not that much. By the end
of Trump's presidency, the economy was looking
pretty OK. And it continued improving under Joe
Biden. We now have a very shaky stock market and
inflation, and we have these global things. But
that trend, we were already seeing it under Trump,
and it continued under Biden. So even the claim
that everything that was done in 2020 hurt the
economy irreversibly, it's just not true. But
maybe more importantly. We learned that it doesn't
matter, even if I try to engage in good faith
and understand where this person is coming from.
I posted about February jobs numbers. The guy
responded and talked about job losses from 2020,
but blamed Biden for them, even though Trump
was president, then changed the conversation to
so-called democratic lockdowns. Even though it was
all under Trump's watch, I mean, it's red herring
after red herring, after straw man after red
herring. So I think what I learned is this is
a waste of my time, and I don't know because
I don't know this Andrew Guy. I don't know
if he's ignorant and maybe cognitively limited
in terms of being able to engage on the facts
or whether he's arguing in bad faith or whether
he's just trolling me, or whether he was confused
or whatever the case may be. I just don't
know, quite frankly. But needless to say,
we didn't learn anything from that conversation,
and I've probably had my fill for at least a
couple of months. But if I decide to do this
again, I'll come, I'll come back to you.